britney spears might just be pregnant
with baby number three yes i love being
a mom i would love to have more kids the
pop icon made the announcement on
instagram telling her fans quote so i
got a pregnancy test and uh well i'm
having a baby but we don't have official
confirmation yet as brit britt also
makes mention of having a food baby in
the post this is just a groundbreaking
day sam also posted hinting at a britney
pregnancy saying he's always wanted to
be a father but he didn't confirm that a
baby is in fact on the way even so her
famous fans are chiming in with their
best wishes she's just
so sweet and down to earth paris hilton
writes in the comments congratulations
sis i'm so excited for you love you
jersey shores jay wow andy cohen and
chloe bailey also chimed in with
congrats brittany shares two kids with
ex-husband kevin federline sons sean
preston and jayden james you want to
have more kids yeah and like
how many more like three more three more
in her announcement the singer shares
she quote obviously won't be going out
as much due to the paps getting their
money shot of me like they unfortunately
already have and you guys know my
situation the announcement follows
britney and sam getting engaged last
year just months before her 13-year
conservatorship came to an end in
november it has been so awesome to see
her enjoy her freedom again how is she
and how are you she's doing great i'm
great i'm just it's the happiest time of
our lives and we're just enjoying it
what's going to be next a wedding
when do you want it to be sooner or
later yeah what kind of wedding do you
want to have what's your dream day you
know it's up to her she's wearing the
pants now during her fight to end her
conservatorship brittany claimed she was
on birth control against her will i
deserve to have the same rights as
anybody does by having a child a family
any of those things
but now it's on to brighter days and
when sam chatted with e.t last month he
said the couple was looking toward the
future what can you tell us about
wedding planning what can you tell us
about bachelor party what can you tell
us about any of the fun stuff that goes
with spending the rest of your life
together i don't think we're going to
have a bad support detail no man batch
of parties are in the past so nobody's a
party what have you guys talked about
moving anywhere special you and brittany
buying a house somewhere fantastic that
we need to know about yeah man
everything's gonna be new from here on
out so you know all all the new stuff
are in
yeah
[Music]